so uh let me start by saying i've really
enjoyed what you've put out this year so
i just want to say uh thank you you i've
really enjoyed it um i'm curious if if
someone has uh has never seen anything
that you've done what's the first thing
you want them to watch
uh doris hello my name is doris is there
a particular reason
um
i i think that that
represents that that's sort of a nexus
point for me of all the different sort
of
things that interest me artistically
it's a it's funny it's a there's an
element of certainty but there's also
a real
a a real humanity there um
obviously like wet hot american summer
and stella and those projects are near
and dear to me um but they don't
that they they're purely comedic
whereas um some of the more recent
things i've done
are
comedic but also have this kind of
this other aspect to it that i think has
is a has become something that's you
know
uh very meaningful to me so hello my
name is doris is sort of like
the first one of those projects where
like the kind of drama was was a was a
major part of it um so but it's also a
very comedic film it also has a lot of
absurdity and silliness to it and um so
so i feel like it's a nice blend of all
the different things that sort of our
influence influenced me
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
what was it about this material that
said i have to do this
um
i i know this world
i myself was in therapy for many many
years in new york city
very close to where i'm sure marty was
in therapy um
so i could picture it i could just see
it
the the offices the streets the
buildings
[Music]
the
the hamptons where a lot of the stories
set i love the hamptons i've spent many
summers there i have many friends who
who have places down there i love going
there i feel like i've been at these
parties that they had i mean not
literally but like i actually have many
friends who
who were
and so it's like this alternate universe
that i was like very cl been very close
to and so i could just picture it as i
was listening to the
podcast i just felt like i knew these
people and i knew this world
and
um
that and and then also just fat being
fascinated by
the
kind of
dark
twisted way in which
the ike character paul rudd's character
manipulates and takes advantage of
marty the will farrell's characters
takes advantage of his vulnerability and
i found that very compelling as well
i'll admit before i watched i was
wondering because i hadn't heard the
podcast how did this actually happen and
as i watched your series i was like oh
this is how it happened it starts so
well and so well-meaning and all of a
sudden it's just little by little the
walls come down
yeah
and i feel like
that's often
what happens with situations like this
where
uh you know
when we were making the shrink next door
was when those documentaries were coming
out about keith renery and nexium i
don't know if you were if you saw any of
those documentaries i've heard a little
bit about it but i'm not as familiar
i mean it's just a very similar kind of
thing of you know
you're kind of a
someone who's kind of like in a weird
place in their life maybe they had a
breakup or they they're you know they're
they're in between jobs and they're like
not feeling happy in some way and then
they start going to this self-help
program and oh my god this is so great
everybody's so great and and you kind of
kind of get sucked in it's sort of like
a cult actually you sort of get sucked
in and that's what happens to marty is
he gets sucked in
by ike and by ike's confidence and by
ike's
enthusiasm and by ike's charming
qualities
and but slowly
it the relationship gets kind of toxic
without marty really understanding it it
almost hap it's like by the time he
realizes
how deep in he is he's too late he's
already
destroyed
you know all of his lifelines have been
used up at that point
was there anything when you were
researching this and getting ready to to
um to film that you were really just
shocked to learn something that just
really stopped you in your tracks
um yes actually um
i don't know how well you know that i
mean i'm assuming you know this story i
don't know if you've seen the whole
series or whatever but
um
so there's a central the central
relationships are ike and marty paul
rudd and and will ferrell but then also
will ferrell and catherine hahn
and catherine hahn plays marty's sister
phyllis
and
one of the things that happens in the
show
is that
uh
ike
paul rudd
drives a wedge into the relationship
between marty and phyllis and basically
they become estranged what i didn't know
is is that they lived
within a block of each other in new york
so they lived literally around the
corner from each other
and
uh did not see each other for 27 years
and they were one they lived one block
away from each other in on the upper
east side
and
uh
or maybe it was the upper west side
but if you've ever lived in new york
to not see somebody that lives one block
away from you for 27 years is like a
mathematical impossibility but also just
so sad
um and
marty says he saw her one time and he
crossed the street
so phyllis says she never saw him once
in 27 years even though they lived one
block from each other
that i did not know this and that is um
i i've been i've spent a lot of time in
new york i agree with what you're saying
yeah it's crazy especially like just a
little supermarket like the local place
by subway the subway you just run into
people on the subway if you're if you're
in if you're in a neighborhood
like you just all take the same subway
like you know maybe you don't see each
other for a couple of years but 27 years
that's one of the things
it's really amazing yeah well you you
always do a very good job at balancing
like humor with heartbreak and i'm just
curious what is it like in the editing
room trying to find that balance or is
it on set that you're figuring that like
you know what i mean like how much is it
on set how much is it in the editing
room is it a combination of i guess both
well you're you're knowing in the in as
you're shooting you're knowing oh this
is that these are those moments that are
going to be
are going to have that feeling to them
and so you're making sure to do
something with the camera
to let the editors know this is a moment
don't you know whether it's pushing in
or changing the frame a little bit
but it's also in the script you know
that it's there in the script and so
hopefully
you know if everyone's doing their job
it all kind of comes out very
organically in the process this is sort
of there in the script and then it's
there in the shooting of it it's there
in the performances and then the editor
knows
whether we might have talked about it or
he just he or she knows instinctively
like
this is a moment to
to
you know and and if it's not that way
then you usually it means that if i'm
not on the same page with the editor
usually it means it's not a good fit so
you usually when i work with an editor
they know that that's the tone i'm
looking for
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say um seriously great job on
this uh i wish you nothing but the best
hope it's a huge hit thanks a lot